[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter Lavelle
an instant media darling and certainly a
fresh-faced the newly minted
congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
is rattling some Democratic
establishment cages she calls herself a
Democratic Socialist and she has some
big plans
it's a Democratic Party and America
ready for a Cosi
[Music]
crosstalking Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
I'm joined by my guest Steve Morgan in
New York he is the conservative
political commentator also in New York
we have Jason Nichols he is a
progressive commentator and Democratic
strategist and in Los Angeles we cross
through a che Goodman he is a columnist
and journalist published in The
Huffington Post salon the hill and other
publications all right gentlemen
crosstalk rolls in effect that means you
can jump in anytime you want and I
always appreciate it Jason let me go to
you first because she comes from your
wheelhouse so I'll let you take a strike
at it first she calls herself a
Democratic Socialist I mentioned that in
the introduction she claims the world as
we know it will end in 12 years and
before she was a became officially a
congresswoman she said that she would be
inaugurated and she would start signing
bills are you very confident that her
understanding of democratic socialism is
something America needs or wants go
ahead Jason so again I think she
misunderstands what democratic socialism
versus social democracy those are two
very different things I think when she
talks about trying to go towards the
Scandinavian model like Norway and
Sweden and other countries have done
that's actually social democracy that's
not democratic socialism so I think she
she has a misunderstanding of a few
things but her overall ideas I think are
positive I think she is a fresh-faced I
think she's a positive prescient
presence for a lot of the older people
in the party who you know operate with
politics as usual we needed someone to
shake things up and I think she's a
great presence okay you get a very good
defense of her she certainly is
inspiring and she seems like a nice
person to know and when she would they
try to denigrate her with her dancing
video I think it only grew her the
people that like her I thought it was a
young person having a good time Wow is
there something wrong with that today
let me go - let me go to AJ in Los
Angeles what's your take of AOC because
she seems like a nice face for the party
but are the policies the right ones for
the country go ahead AJ in Los Angeles
well speaking of the policies
congresswoman Alexandra occasion Cortes
promised to abolish ice
she promised medicare-for-all she
promised a green new deal a $15 minimum
wage free tuition these are all ideas
that need to be drafted into legislation
congresswoman Cortes has not she does
not have a bill that she's drafted so
that tells me that she's not serious
about actually implementing Medicare for
all and that leads to the fact that
Bernie Sanders was cheated by Hillary
Clinton the congresswoman Cortes knows
very well that Democrats cheated Bernie
Sanders they stole 200 million dollars
from Bernie voters which is why Jared
Beck Elizabeth Beckett Nikko house waged
the DNC fraud lawsuit then Democrats
blamed Russia with quote-unquote
evidence that was linked to money from
Hillary Clinton and the Democratic Party
and so you have a situation where this
new class of progressive people in
Congress they're essentially doing what
many pundits on TYT on YouTube do what
CNN MSNBC what a great deal of people do
they they actively deceive voters by
saying Medicare for all is going is
right around the corner and then when
Alexandria Kaiser Cortez is in Congress
she is not pushing Medicare for all
legislation there is no bill that
Democrats are uniting around their
location okay maybe that's fun let me go
let me go to Steve first then we'll make
it a free-for-all here Steve I mean you
know it she she's very empathetic okay
and I kind of kind of echoing a little
bit what h.a had to say there I mean
these are nice words and she's emotional
and the meet liberal media loves it I
mean in her last public speaking you
know people have to take responsible
well when is anybody in government ever
taken responsibility for anything I mean
the words are nice but you know and it's
very naive and it has a nice gentle
touch but the country has hard hard
problems and really difficult choices to
make and she's certainly not sued
for at least you know so far in who
knows maybe she'll be elected president
one day I don't know jump in Steve go
ahead in New York well well as you
alluded to you know she's planning on
signing these bills not drafting
legislation so maybe she's waiting for
the bill to come to her death so she
could sign it I mean she's the gift that
keeps on giving
my goodness if this if this is the face
of the Democrat Party bring it on
you know she's one of the very few
Democrats who keeps voting against
reopening the government the bill that
keeps passing the house over and over
again that Nancy Pelosi keeps bringing
up you know why she said she didn't vote
for it she won't vote for it because it
funds ice immigration and customs
enforcement she wants to abolish ice you
know what a radical idea that is the
reason you'll never see substance from
her and real bills is because if she has
to draft legislation the price tag
the radicalness if you will of her views
will come out and be there on the record
instead of the smiley face on all the
late-night talk shows there'll be
radical substance and people will say
whoa that's not good okay Jason and
Steve it's taking us to the point where
I want to continue I mean you know
before the the midterms you didn't have
a lot of mainstream Democrats talking
about the abolition of ice but now you
have more and more associated in in the
establishment here I mean to what degree
is she she as a person and as a media
personality which she's very good at
okay she's good on Twitter I've been
following her okay how much is she
pulling the party to the left and is
that in sync with what most people in
the country want go ahead Jason in New
York I think it is I think in 2018 and
in the midterms we saw the American
people basically there was a referendum
on the direction of the country and I
think people are becoming more
progressive you know I think what one of
your guests was saying out there in LA I
believe it was a che was saying look the
country actually wants progressive
policy I think it's a little unfair to
say that you know she hasn't
drafted this legislation yet when we
have a government shutdown right now to
think about and we actually are oh
they've only been in Congress for about
three weeks so far but I will say that
the I think the country is moving in
that direction the abolition of ice I
think is makes for a nice hashtag but
what people really mean is a rebranding
of ice meaning things need to change we
don't need to focus on getting you know
the average guy who's selling fruit or
not hurting anybody we need to focus on
transnational gangs and and human
trafficking and many other things that
that Isis tasks to do so this is the and
Isis going in a different direction
right now under this president so I
think really we also have to remember
that ice is a new organization they
going after I go ahead see go ahead
Steve I say under Donald Trump is ice
under Donald Trump is going after fruit
stand guys and not gangs my goodness
here's the yes they are truth
stay yeah okay there was a poll Dudley
right right there was a poll done the
other day that said hey do you favor
Medicare for all 70 some-odd percent
said yes then when the question is asked
are you willing to pay more taxes to
fund Medicare for all it dropped the 37
percent when reality comes in to these
proposals the American people will say
well no way okay hey let me go to H a
because again you guys who hang okay
hang on let's equal time for everyone
here OHA I mean the whole I didn't
really want to talk about I so much but
I mean again this has changed the name
change the image what about policy what
about what they do okay because I watch
the liberal media they they're given a
really bad rap okay because it feels
good I don't care what people feel I
think we need policy to make people's
lives better go ahead a che when you
look at ice and you look at President
Obama's tenure he deported 2.5 million
document and immigrants and there's a
New York magazine article Obama
administration handed child migrants
over the human traffickers this is in
Jan on January 29 2016 there was a
Senate report regarding the abuses under
the during the Obama administration but
when you talked about Medicare for all
and all these these policy ideas that
Alexandra occasion Cortez has not
drafted there's no bill that that people
in Congress and Democrats will pass
before 2020 because they're not going to
go into the 2020 election doubling or
tripling tax collections like the
Mercator study said but aside from that
it's President Trump who is bringing
home close to 10,000 Americans from
Syria and Afghanistan that ISM that is a
great as an amazing thing it's President
Trump was presiding over peace hopefully
the start of peace between North and
South Korea these are all amazing things
where is Alexandria occasi Cortes where
is where any Democrats saying yeah bring
home our soldiers from never-ending
counterinsurgency war but so perhaps we
can pay policies you're not saying that
you'd get the memo H a because now the
Democrats are the party of war okay
they're the party of war on steroids
okay Jason let me finish up with you and
in this section of the program do the
Democratic does the Democratic
establishment do they fear people like
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez in your party
so I think the the moderate Democrats
fear her I think you know there are
people who are red state Democrats who
may be afraid because you know they they
kind of have to toe a certain line I
think some of the older establishment
people certainly fear her you're gonna
see people during this election cycle
this presidential election they're all
gonna be seeking her endorsement yeah so
she's a very powerful person and
powerful people are feared so I
certainly believe that there are people
who
want her out of the spotlight
yeah but she's being helped by the
right-wing media who can't take the guys
off okay I got it I gotta jump in here
gentlemen we're gonna go to a short
break well I'd like to say that I hope
anyone that puts the fear of God into
these people I would support to one
degree or another okay we're gonna go to
a short break and after that short break
we'll continue our discussion on AOC
stay with our team welcome back to
crosstalk where all things are
considered I'm Peter LaBelle to remind
you were discussing AOC
[Music]
okay let's go back to Steve in New York
the fact that AOC has been put on the
Oversight Committee in the House of
Representatives tells me a lot she's
good for the camera she'll be good for
talking points of course they're gonna
be starting a whole array of
investigations than into Trump his
family his businesses and they want her
front and center don't they it's a PR
move as well I'm not deny she was she
was legitimately and fairly elected and
I wish her the best of luck however she
will be used by the party and the media
Steve yes she will but but then she's
gonna have to face you know her
questions and her questioning in her
back and forth if she's gonna have to
face people who are polished and know
what they're saying I mean they may be
perceived by many as he as the bad guy
whether it's the Trump family or Trump
administration members or whomever but
she's gonna have to have an intelligent
conversation and understand the depth of
her questions and what she's implying on
what the answer is mean and I got to
tell you you know she will be the first
to tell you that she's not up on this
she's not up on that she's no expert on
this and if she's if that's what she
comes off as in these hearings it's not
gonna be good for her and she will fade
away very fast well Steve on that point
there I saw the interview with her
discussing the palestinian-israeli
conflict that she really fell flat on
her face on that one I hope and she did
she did it do degree in international
relations that's kind of interesting
Jason you were disagreeing I knew you
would that's why you're on the program
go yeah absolutely well first of all
what I thought was was interesting I
agree that a AOC has some factual issues
and sometimes she speaks in hyperbole
like her issue or her comment about the
world ending in 12 years
but I mean when you sit there and you
say I mean Steve almost had me when he
was talking about you know she needs to
know her facts like the Trump family
that's what I was like okay these are
people who in people working in the
White House according to Bob Woodward
who was probably the greatest journalist
of our generation you know basically
said that the president's an idiot and
that
doesn't know what he's talking about you
know we've seen all of the generals I
will see how cozy Italy the madis to all
of them and and you know we see he's a
very charismatic person he's a New York
City guy so he's able to to you know
sell certain things and and as far as
Syria I think Democrats want to bring
people home from Syria - we just want to
do it in a responsible way which is what
general mattis and other people have
said hey you're hitting a real we're
getting a real nerve with me so I think
we should take Syria of the table for
this program here and stick with the
Democrats okay so let me go to AJ AJ in
Los Angeles I mean one can one could say
that you know I'm sorry that state stay
with the Democrats in a OC okay how is
the identity politics here working out
is this something that you think the
Democrats are going to continue to
pursue within their own party because
the more they do that then where's the
place for Joe Biden where's the place
for Bernie Sanders because well there's
a number of things against them they're
straight they're white they're old
they're rich
certainly Biden is here I mean it seems
to me that this whole identity politics
in the Democratic Party and it's it's a
dragon that will eventually eat its tail
go ahead a che in Los Angeles well I
don't think identity politics or any
form of politics on the Left will ever
work if you don't have Alexandria Kaiser
Cortes and other Democrats speaking
against the max boot Hillary Clinton
foreign policy that says we have to ask
Assad we should never a President Obama
should never have sent Americans to
Syria that in close proximity with
Russian forces we don't need World War
three that is that was the worst foreign
policy decision one of the worst in
addition to President Obama
destroying Libya with a failed NATO
intervention but the the issue is this
there's no push to bring Americans home
from war President Trump is bringing
close to 10,000 from
Afghanistan and Syria this is a very
good thing if indeed Alexandria occasi
Cortez really wanted all the lofty
ideals and policy objectives then she
would say bring Americans home from war
we can save a hundred bill over a
hundred billion dollars a year and
trillions in the long run a plane we're
paying trillions also an interest you
know a che you know you know what's
going on here they don't want to give
Trump anything even when he's right and
he's right sometimes and he's wrong
sometimes but give credit where credit
is due you hit that third rail on me
and I really want to stick with with a
OC here Steve look like you want to jump
in go ahead yeah yeah I'll go back get
away from Syria you're absolutely right
I I know what you're thinking what you
said I agree with you but let me let me
move on to this identity politics see I
think the Republicans are missing a huge
opportunity here you know who the only
person was that took Nancy Pelosi to
task when she referred to five white men
and they should open a hamburger stand
Steny Hoyer in her own party because he
was one of those white men I think that
the Democrat the Republican Party should
demand and and and ask people like
Ocasio Cortez you know to denounce when
somebody in their party says Oh angry or
old white men because that's racist and
sexist and by remaining silent the
Republicans are just conceding that
point when it's outrageous to me that
they were allowed to just demean white
men and they might as well spit after
they say wait Steve is hitting another
third rail on the other side that
Kavanagh and I'm a process you know that
was a disgrace and the biggest disgrace
in public in my lifetime okay and Jason
the Democrats acquitted themselves in
the most disgusting way and I have to
wonder where personal integrity is in
America these days because what he was
done what was the senator from Hawaii
men should shut up no we need to talk
more not less okay go ahead Jason
so again like I said two words Steve
King and the Republicans coddled a known
white supremacist and said nothing
president has said nothing let me tell
you some who you push what help joy
excuse me I'm speaking excuse me George
W Bush when Trent Lott said something
that was even remotely remotely racist
George W Bush called it out and you know
marginalize Trent Lott however the
Republican Party has changed since then
and they they coddled these guys that's
how guys like Arthur Jones and Corey
Stewart run as Republicans even though
they're known white supremacists this is
why you know you have white supremacist
descend on Washington DC nothing about
that's what's problematic the problem
what's problematic here is the debt
damage there's nothing about it the
Democrats in the left always played the
race card now they always play the
misogyny card now it's there
that's the that's the flush they hold in
their hand because they don't have any
good ideas to improve the life of people
all they do is a walk through a race
you're racist you're a misogynist you
know that's all you do that's all I hear
from CNN and MSNBC a 24/7 okay they
never talk about policy go ahead let
Jason when you know that Hillary Clinton
Oh Jason he's obviously not gonna let
Jason respond and Jason does Jason will
respond oh well again yeah here's a
here's an answer to that is for the
Republicans to stop being racist and
misogynist if they stop doing that then
people won't have to call it out and we
can actually start having conversations
of substantive conversations about how
we can better things for all Americans
but that's not what the okay we're
chasing our tail on this okay I don't
believe that Donald Trump is a racist
whatsoever I don't I and and then you
would people like you Jason with all due
respect and I always like when you come
on this part
here you were people and your circle of
friends were willing to destroy a man's
career based on no evidence after seven
FBI investigations and you still said
you want to delay and you want more
investigations which Hillary Clinton
would be really investigated and your
word all use instead of being caught old
okay H a go ahead jump in it was Hillary
Clinton not President Trump who referred
to black youth as super predators
Hillary Clinton also spread a photo this
is according to the Guardian of Barack
Obama take advantage of the xenophobia
in 2000 yes she actually did Clinton it
was it was Hillary Clinton the other day
without any condemnation who said all
black people look alike
nobody called her out on that in the
Democratic Party in fact they defended
her so when Hillary Clinton calls black
youth super predators suddenly she's not
a white supremacist there's nothing that
President Trump has said as horrible and
is degrading and as insulting is that
the issue with the Democratic Party is
that when it's a person whether it's
keith ellison who was accused of abusing
a woman nobody talks about it because
democrats are a bunch of hypocrites if
it's something some no witnesses keith
Ellison's accuser had medical records no
medical records with Cavanagh no
witnesses no location no exact time but
Democrats were suddenly suddenly
appalled and they want to destroy
Cavanaugh's life keith Ellison nobody
talks about Bill Clinton
nobody's talks about so Democrats never
call out races every time the Democratic
Party was impeached and they never call
out anti-semitism in the Democratic
Party when they said Bernie Sanders
should go ahead and cheat him
yeah let me just know because they have
the Harvey Weinstein doctrine and Steve
I want to give you the last word you've
been very patient go ahead yeah no no I
mean at Bill you could bring up Bill
Clinton who excuse Robert Byrd for
joining the KKK at his funeral he said
he had her he had to get elected
Hillary called Robert Byrd the KKK man
her mentor you have Joe Biden who said
Barack Obama was the first clean clean
particulate man or black person to run
for president when many others ran
before he said education is better in
Iowa than in Washington DC cuz look how
many minorities you have in DC compared
to Iowa I mean any even one of these
statements from a Republican would have
ruined them for life there is a
double-slit aides to Steve lemon we've
had a very robust discussion and we're
still good friends okay many thanks to
my guest in New York and in Los Angeles
and thanks to our viewers for watching
us here at RT see you next time and
remember crosstalk was
[Music]